ce que tu peux nous confirme aujourd'hui
que tu n'es plus sur delphine si aussi
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je vais te dire
une phrase trop de culte on aimerait
aujourd'hui je me positionne sur un dos
tu vas nous le dira tonneins
pionnat audrey bonsoir
nous sommes à quelques encablures des
fêtes de noël
et chacun bien sûr envie de trouver
son petit sapin
c'est donc ces sapins sans épines
avec des belles boules
tu peux faire ce serait bien s'il vous
plaît adoptez plus de tiana
aujourd'hui
guillaume est à la croisée des chemins
guillaume c'est quelqu'un qui aime la
vie c'est quelqu'un qui aime l'amour
est malheureusement guillaume
n'a pas un coeur d'artichaut
il a un coeur
avec un champs d'artichauts
c'est à dire que dès qu'il voit
quelqu'un c'est pour femmes hommes
[Musique]
animaux
n'ont pas ni modularité
est interdit aux hommes
qui sont amoureux et se sent pousser des
ailes c'est vrai ya aujourd'hui a besoin
de savoir avec qui va passer dès le 24
décembre aujourd'hui guillaume
à deux personnes en tête fiona
et voudrait way autant vous dire que
vous êtes dans les petits papiers oui là
là guillaume est célibataire
[Musique]
merci
guillaume
est ce que celle sur qui vous avez jeté
votre dévolu oui
je vous ai pas encore présent question
du prêt c est autour de la table ce soir
réponse est oui
[Musique]
la première question est ce une fille ou
un garçon ah
désolé mathieu c'est une fille il faut
dire aussi désole bernard il est volé
gilles
est ce que la personne
est né avant 1825
effectivement
et petits mois après elle est prête et
rentable alors dit au revoir donc à une
personne de la belle qui quitte
l'aventuré
[Rires]
ne reste plus que trois prétendantes
est-ce que
là personne sur qui vous avez jeté votre
dévolu on
est quelqu'un
qui aime
la lecture
pas trop je ne crois pas désolé
géraldine faudrait vous êtes encore
parmi nous
il parle de sa mère est ce parce qu un
ordre et qu'il y beaucoup
croisé cet été oui à la plage on s'est
croisé quoi exactement
non mais c'est exactement mais je vous
jure que c'est vrai la plage vous dont
je suis passé non c'est vrai que vous
avez rencontrées ne commence à
m'emmerder est ce que c'est moi mon
soutien de deux de mes vêtements la
norme et rodrigues on a eu la chance de
se croiser dès cet été n'a
pas du tout vous raconter comment s'est
passé c'est vrai après on verra je te
comme sa petite parenthèse j'ai des
copains qui étaient sur une plage à
cannes et ils me disent franchement
c'est le feu vient ils me font une vidéo
de genre c'est la folie tout le monde
danse et dans cette vidéo subit mais y
aurait donc je viens comme en mille
collines unis qui travaillent avec moi
audrey il dit bah ouais balle avec nous
et là il jeudi battue est passé et en
fait j'ai jamais passé alors pourquoi
chaque comme d'habitude mais je veux pas
de lui mais attendu tout l'été sur des
vagues j'arrive à tshela dans deux
minutes il facile de se garer oui bah
oui c'est pas si facile voilà donc
audrey et donc donc j'ai vu dans ses
chais une vidéo d'elle en train de
danser sur la plage il y règne dans ces
extraits c'est la ceinture elle était en
jeu c'est la seule qui peut faire ça si
si vous êtes de à faire ça non mais
c'est vrai franchement il ya bernard
werber réel
rectifier les aime la lecture d'accord
très bien donc aujourd'hui on le sait il
ne reste plus que deux prétendantes
puis on a
et audrey
audrey et fiona
ma première question
ce que vous aimez la mode
oui à du tout pas du tout
[Musique]
le père noël quand même un s2 deuxième
question est ce que vous aimez
la coloration les colorations la
décoloration ou la décoloration fiona ça
dépend turquie c'est à dire les
personnels qui ça va très bien d'autres
un peu moins pourrait citer deux
exemples une balade
qui sont autour la table dont la vie
dj snake par exemple saluer très très
bien voilà d'accord et à qui ça ne va
pas mathieu pas trop
ça va cesser combien d'accords donc ça
va
audrey
audrey oui j'aime et décoloration des
doigts
ben amor guillaume
vous allez dire jusqu'où pour y aller
pour séduire ou audrey où fiona alors je
veux dire je suis pas venu les mains
vides si ce match c'est que je suis un
homme de lettres bien sûr j'ai écrit un
petit poème cette nuit puisque j'avais
pas à dormir non c'est vrai que pour
audrey c'est audrey
audrey
l'amour frappe à votre porte encore une
fois cet amour
c'est beau il est là il est en pyjama
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez vider votre poème nation pour
l'instant mode et vous allez bien sûr
écouter ce poème et après bien sûr si
audrey est d'accord si audrey adhèrent à
cette prose
audrey guillaume
roux ce qui va laisser les pour le
restant de leurs jours
une demande en mariage ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la danse de l'amour
en espagnol inna modja mais
[Rires]
guillaume
ce n'est pas aux chroniqueurs que je
vais m'adresser c'est à l'amoureux
transi au poète à l'homme de lettres
à l'homme qui a laissé tomber ses
chiffres ces chiffres d'audience c'est
pile en fin d'année pour des lettres des
lettres n'ont pas persane et lettres
d'amour avec un grand a
comme arcade
[Rires]
j'ai un peu tordu en effet audrey ce
soir sur le plateau de thé pmp je suis
venu d'ouvrir mon coeur est peut-être ma
cb
il sera tué le beauf
cb ma carte bancaire
papa tu es la seule qui ne met pas dit
adieu j'ai dragué wespiser fiona et même
ce bon vieux mathieu
je vois dans tes yeux que tu es déjà
conquise toi et moi je le sens on va
faire des bêtises
alors merci baba pour cette belle passe
dès ce soir je suis ton killian mbp et
crois-moi frérot je vais la mettre au
fond des filets
[Applaudissements]
suis pas sûr qu'elle soit très élégante
alors ça n'a rien à voir on part le foot
aux
[Applaudissements]
rencontres adressé une foire et foot
c'était la soirée de marquinhos foot
qu'elle adore le foot audrey mais oui il
adore alors venir du coup audrey
maintenant ma question est simple s'est
gratté vous on et ghislain les métiers
non pas du tout là c'est pas du tout ça
la question n'est pas dans les bêtises
parce qu imposerait ma question est
simple
vous voulez vous ce soir
prendre pour époux et
oui car il y met le chérir
jusqu'à ce coup de couleur vous sépare
l rosie légèrement
jusqu à l envie de péter
[Rires]
bonjour d'emosson mais qu'est ce qui lui
prend ça m'arrangerait tu dhabi on se
connaît depuis des années c'est vrai
diab était devant moi c'est vrai c'est
une amie sabah gêne pas entre nous
est-ce que tu y es ce que tu es prête va
péter à faire la danse de l'amour avec
guillaume
et
pourquoi au réfléchir non alors je vais
dire quand c'est un nom comme ça que je
penserais pas besoin de réfléchir
guillaume veux-tu peut-être bifurquer
quelqu'un sur un itinéraire bis
c'est pas toi tu es belle
c'est david non je parle me touche
absolument pas je suis avec delphine de
toute façon d'accord
on m'a dit je ne m'en cache pas non mais
vous avez raison audrey on peut savoir
la raison nos voisins la raison c'est
que depuis tout à l'heure on dit non non
surtout pas surtout pas c'est pas du
tout moi qui n'assume pas ses choix
alors là vous ne voulez pas lancé non
gens dans la merde vis-à-vis de delphine
bâton et complémentaires j'ai été très
fière de ses complices rôderait est ce
que vous pourriez danser avec ios il
vous disait pas non ça dépend quel genre
le dansant c'est tout ce qu'on appelle
stains
merengue
biceps amis meringue
on est comme ça tu vois on est là
mais
les meringues et wissam il aura
guillaume votre réponse est oui votre
réponse est non parce que guillaume là
je voudrais aller non mais j'ai beaucoup
de problèmes en ce moment mais
on essaiera rené de faire un poème oui
mais voilà je ne veux pas aller plus
loin malheureusement
des gens non mais lui avait dit qu'il
avait une balle année ils sont nommés tu
arrêtes toi non mais là où toi mais
c'est vrai mais va sur fiona
cairns
l'animé s'étaient
[Applaudissements]
perdus
font des choix sur ces quatre séries sur
le la du tout à ça alors mais quand on
partait l'hyper près de
premier choix bien sûr si on était
premiers bébés bâillent ces sites et
autres le bien labrador
et des deux celui qui remue la queue
non mais c'est quoi donc dit
non non c'est bon cette vidéo non non ça
va lorsque c'est trop tard ou est ce que
ça aurait pu annonce la norvège avait
abondamment suis très vexé non mais
c'est une question de devecser aussi
c'est une question régulation on peut
situer dans une émission enregistrée je
peux revenir au départ
du tout franchement au la toule
maintenant je ne veux pas partir légumes
en revanche je veux bien danser avec
guillaume
[Applaudissements]
journée de championnat est une très
grande danseuse élégance et broc pas je
sais pas pendant des années je vous la
regardez celle annoncée non mais
[Applaudissements]
tu vas aller ranger tes jouets dans sa
chambre et tu vois tu vas venir gagnent
parce que là est là mais si on déconnait
cette bague chaumet faire alors je peux
te dire ça et je t'adore une meuf ne
peut pas avoir envie de kent avec un mec
qui a des choses et matteo armés sont
arrivés et je peux te dire et robinson
envie de voir ton nuggets
[Rires]
voulait perdre 1000 dans une petite
enfance l autre et non il m'a dit va
trés après d'abord chennai ah oui
alice la musique pas mettez de la
musique bordel
non
[Musique]
étatiques
huawei
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à wroclaw
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à calais
il ya une rigolade il a faim regard de
bg la
très mal à l'aise
et bien l'argent parce que sinon on n'en
a pas mal audrey vous fait d'être est
très bonne et aux halles et audrey
voulez danser ou pas du tout
de ce cadeau a dit quand elle voit la
liste
[Applaudissements]
mais dans ce cas
mais pas du tout votre femme d'or a été
le bordel dans ma vie à chaque émission
quand même c'est une maladie vous avez
enfin un divorce non mais
je remercie non merci c'est sale et laid
charmante et très jeune
j'ai très envie ou pas non mais tout est
mon style toute façon
[Applaudissements]
voilà benjamin castaldi bien sûr en tout
cas vous êtes très très beau mais riche
et pull mais très bien vraiment votre
belle pointe